this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice dr john deloney ramsey
personality best-selling author
is my co-host today he's also the host
of the dr john delony show
on podcast and it is exploding
the hockey stick up and to the right the
numbers are
scary it's um
probably surprising to some of your
friends how popular you are
it's distressing it's distressing you
are
the answering questions about life and
about relationships and we'll throw
those in with the money questions today
folks since he's sitting here beside me
we both like getting into the boundary
questions and the questions about
spouses and relationships and crazy
brother-in-laws and all that crap and
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's start with
maria this hour in chicago hi maria
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave very excited to talk to you
thank you so much
um my question my question is this it's
going to be
uh well i guess i'll ask the question
first and then i'll give you the
background
okay is it financial is it friendly just
financially speaking
not not regarding how i feel about home
ownership just financially speaking
i'm 58 years old i
i have no debt i have fully funded
emergency
fund i have fully funded retirement both
roth and 401k
how much i own my how much is in it
there's about a million in it okay good
for you well done between the
between the both i raised my four kids
they're all out of college
um i'm single and i my house home's
worth about 350
and i paid it off it's paid off okay
taxes are really high
taxes are really high in illinois
okay but anyway so i i think i want to
downsize because i don't need my house
anymore
cool and i'm not i i so i would go to
like a townhouse
okay so just financially just
financially speaking
it wouldn't be a really bad idea for the
next 30 years for me just to rent
and the reason why i asked that is
because in my heart i've had so much
responsibility in my whole life raising
my four kids keeping up with my house i
wouldn't mind just writing a check every
month and just be done
and uh finally but everybody's telling
me like financially speaking
you could sell your house to 350. go buy
something for 250 or less
i'm like but then i thought you know
then i gotta worry about the house again
the windows the roofs the gutters that
all that you know
[Music]
the question no yeah it makes a lot of
sense i understand
so uh did you raise your kids by
yourself or your single mom for the most
part i mean i was divorced and they were
very very young he was he was
so for 20 years for 20 years you've been
a she-bear out here fighting
scratching clawing and you've cleaned
the gutters you've done whatever it took
and you're just tired
yes i work overtime every month at work
sure i was
yeah i thought you were there i thought
you were that girl you sound like that
girl
you sound like a warrior a warrior
princess um
so uh well let's first answer your
question then let's try to look for a
solution
okay the problem with your the good part
about your theory is you don't have to
screw with stuff because the landlord
does
so you get all this stuff out of your
life the bad part about this
is think about what rents have done
in the last 30 years
and think about what they're going to do
during the 30 years that we're talking
so if you rent instead of owning a paid
for property going into retirement
you're destabilizing your life because
every year your housing cost is going to
go up
true so that's why it's a bad plan
it's not a bad plan to rent for a short
period of time while you're rearranging
things or you're in a transitionary
stage or something like that
but renting for 30 years means you are a
victim of the real estate market
instead of riding the wave can i throw
something else at you
yep okay so i put down on paper because
this has been like uh
stressing me out so i put down on paper
my taxes
versus all my bills in my house i think
you need to move
okay but like i i even projected class
if i was in the townhouse
yeah here's what here's what i want you
to here's what i would do
if you're my little sister and you're
old enough to be my little sister okay
oh i'm not not your older sister no i'm
60
so i got you beat but the uh uh
but so uh i would tell you
you don't want to work on crap and you
don't want crap breaking
and you are a millionaire so you need to
go a
buy a brand new condominium
where someone does all the exterior
maintenance and every
appliance and everything inside is brand
freaking new
you earned it you're a rock star and you
need to enjoy a little bit of this money
and it's like buying a really nice car
that's in really good shape after you've
been driving a freaking beater
and it breaks down all the time and you
know my cars don't break down
now back when i had crap cars
because i was trying to get here they
broke down all the time
but you're you're a warrior girl and you
need to you need to enjoy
the spoils of the battles that you have
won and that's a million dollars in a
350 000 paid for house
you're worth a million and a half
dollars i want you to sell this house i
want you buy 350
000 condo you may want to move
uh to an area that is that probably
might feel a little bit oh like it's a
little too richie rich for you but you
need to live there anyway
wow okay i'll think about this thank you
very good information what do you think
john
yeah i think that transition when you
it's when you're a single mom when
you're raising kids
and you're putting them through college
and you're saving you're working you're
doing overtime
it's kind of like being gazelle intense
for 20
30 years yeah and suddenly your uh your
identity is
i'm a sprinter i'm a fighter that's what
i do yeah and how do you settle back
down you could hear like
man for someone who's accomplished what
she's accomplished the fact that this
decision is keeping her up means it's
not about this decision
it's about i've got to shift gears and
become something else right
that's a big big transition yeah what do
you do when you come home
from a 20-year campaign
on the road with alexander the great and
you're one of his soldiers after 20
years how do you
stop fighting and scratching you will
pick from
your neighbors with your dog how do you
stop it you know and so
you know and that's what she is she's a
warrior princess that's right and so
you know she's been these single moms
man they get her done
these are some of the toughest people in
our planet
and um so yeah that that's uh uh
and that's who she is and and she's like
i you know she's kind of telling herself
good
things like i deserve a rest that's
right and dave we talk a lot about
people making decisions out of stress
or out of um anxiousness that's very
similar to making
decisions out of exhaustion i'm just i'm
done i'm out
right i just want to i know the math is
bad i know it's going to destabilize me
20 years from now
i'm exhausted i don't want to fix
anything i'm excited
i don't want to talk to any more
freaking repairmen i've talked to people
who get divorced because i'm just tired
of it
right so i love your i love your idea of
man right now it feels good
it's not going to be good down the road
no it's a bad long-term plan yeah
yeah i would buy something brand and
investigate the builder make sure it's
an incredibly
high-end high-quality builder
so you are living in a luxury situation
in terms of the service you're going to
be provided as well as the goods
love it you've earned it you're a
millionaire
way to go this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease
christian health care ministries
or chm is not health insurance
but rather a federally approved
exemption to the health care law
it's a time-tested model to help take
care of your health care costs
it's christians helping other christians
by sharing each other's medical bills
adjusting to a new system of paying for
health care
was kind of tricky but that's where chm
stepped in
and they really helped navigate that
water
with the hospital and the payment want
to see if chm is the right fit for your
health care needs
check out our website at
chministries.org backslash
budget that's chministries.org
backslash budget it was just such a
relief to know
that financial burden was going to be
taken care of
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today so if you have questions
about life
relationships mental health
questions as well challenges even
give us a call anxiety depression all
these kinds of things show up here they
show up on the dr john delony show
all the time as well got a wonderful
best-selling book out of one of our
quick reads it's an 80-page quick read
called redefining anxiety
and of course you can uh email john if
you want to have your question
answered on the dr john dolone show if
you want to be on his podcast
it is a a uh a talk radio type podcast
format like
this is so email ask john ramsey
solutions dot com
ask john ramsey solutions dot com or you
can leave a voicemail at 844-693-3291
or you can get in by calling right now
triple eight eight two five
five two two five the lines are full but
we'll get you in quick as we can
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself
why blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping
new promos all the time and always use
the promo code ramsey it's magical
it'll save you money john our question
today's question comes from josephine in
nebraska
what a great name we're on baby step two
with about 20
000 dollars in debt left to pay off
which will take about 18 months
i had an opportunity to pick up a side
hustle that's in my sweet spot that
would allow us to shave off at least
nine months off baby step two
when i told my husband about this his
first response oh boy
can you even i can't imagine saying this
to our world can you read it can you can
you even read it
his first response was then i'll have to
do everything around the house
so in order to avoid an argument i
declined the job
now the same opportunity's been offered
to me again i spoke to him about it and
get the same response
how do i deal with this selfishness two
before
i was gonna say i i think my wife
would stab me in the forehead with a
fork
i mean come on good
god what a child what an immature i
don't know man what a child
little boy yeah i you're gonna be
miserable
you'll be miserable dude until you wake
up and learn how to serve
other people our greatest joy comes
in serving others it is a paradox
right it doesn't sound like it but
you're you're gonna be most happy
young man when you learn to serve
and um and by the way this woman is not
gonna
you're gonna be doing everything around
your house in short order my brother
because you're gonna be the only one
there buddy
the only one there she's uh
or you may not be living that's yeah one
of the two you got a fork in your you
know you've been duct taped to
something when you're asleep you know oh
my gosh
josephine you got i mean yeah when
you're dealing with someone this
immature
this um unwilling to
to hear your heart on a number of
different things man because this is
bigger than just paying off
this is about it's bigger than housework
yes man this is about you finding
yourself
everything's about him okay uh here's
now all now that we've vented and uh are
mad at the little wuss
um let's how do you actually fix this i
would say
if you're not in a good church and there
are good churches and there are
toxic misses but find a good church
where the people are healthy
mentally spiritually emotionally find an
older couple
and get them involved in your life and
that guy
in that older couple will take your
husband out in the backyard and explain
things to him
explain things don't you think yeah i
mean
or get a good pastor involved or even
get to a marriage counselor not now
junior birdman here is not going to
marriage counseling because he's too
cool for school
but uh you need to go and learn how to
talk to him
about how this is going to end up for
him
because my experience with this stuff
john i'm not i'm i don't have the phds
and all this other stuff
i've just watched it too often even in
our friends group over the years you
know you go through the stages of
everybody's getting married then
everybody's having kids then everybody's
getting divorced that's right
and so you know and i've done enough
financial
coaching over the 30 years that i see
this
ladies in particular and i don't know
it's not sexist i think it's
um they they they boil
until they reach a point and then when
the switch flips it's off
they're done right you can't get them
back you can't
reel it back in guys will kind of go
out there and then come back and we're
back in right but
uh you know once she flip once her
switch flips
uh junior birdman you're in trouble yeah
because you will have lost her she will
not be you cannot retrace these steps
right
because she will put up with this and i
don't want first i didn't want to or
our argument now she's out saying it out
loud how do i deal with this selfishness
and then if this just continues and he
doesn't get better she's going to have
enough
and there's nobody can talk her out of
it there's no amount of bible teaching
about divorce it's going to work
she's just going to be done because
somebody for the second time has told
her
i value you and i'd like you to come
join us right
and somebody in her childhood didn't
tell her that this guy surely didn't
tell her that
and this is bigger than a job this is
somebody saying
hey man i see something valuable in you
so much come join us
and that's what somebody says no to
right that's what somebody says i'm
gonna go towards where somebody values
me right
and so josephine you gotta have you
gotta get somebody else that you can
talk to about this
and because there's bigger stuff here
but at the end of the day you're gonna
have to have
dave you said it i'll say it in a
nerdier way you're gonna have to have
your or what conversation
and you gotta have somebody with some
wisdom before you do that otherwise
you're gonna react
and i don't want it to build up i want
you to get some tools to
let this to by incrementally
increase the heat under him instead of
you just increasing the heat inside of
you and you finally just blow up and
the switch flips and you're done right
because that's that's what this
i i see this a lot yeah and i don't i
don't
i don't i understand when the switch
flips right when you're dealing with
this type of immaturity i get it
all you can work on
[Laughter]
we got one sentence right and we're
already through with him how can he get
through the dead come
good josephine yeah man and can you
imagine dylan's sharing this oh i'm just
trying to think of saying sheila oh oh
oh you don't even want to think about it
what what how a hillbilly woman react to
that that would not be good i'm just
saying
she would you give you a look that would
say like chapters
no my skin would peel off like indiana
jones too it would just all blow off
it would melt it would melt off your
eyes would blow out of your head yeah
like when they
when they touched the ark of the
covenant man
yeah josephine i'm so sorry man yeah and
whoever this guy's
if your wife comes to you and says hey i
i've got an opportunity to help i want
to help too
let your first response be awesome
let's it's going to be some stuff we got
to figure out but let's
figure it out i will work on this
together it does mean i'm going to have
to pick up all the housework but let's
talk about this yeah you know that's a
one way to answer this is like yeah
yeah i like sitting on my butt in the
recliner
man i'll tell you what oh we do have
we do have a manhood crisis in america
real men
know how to serve and vacuum and vacuum
that's serving i know it's one thing
especially when it's
you're dirt on the floor [ __ ] godly
dude
i don't do the dishes yes you do they're
yours
williams in new york city hey william
what's up
william william hung up william is
married to josephine
yes i'm here i'm sorry i was on mute oh
that's okay my fault how can we help
dave pleasure for having me i appreciate
it um so
just kind of sum it up i'm 27 i make
about
70 uh k a year plus stock incentives
i contribute about six percent to a raw
401k
been doing it since day one and i also
commit uh 10 percent
to uh stocks via our employee purchase
program
um which has a 15 um they all do
discount which is great they all do um i
have about 10
in a private uh i had about 15
sorry i had about 25 and see any credit
card how much
how much do you have in in employee
stock
um currently about 15 grand cash it out
and pay off your debt
cash it i'll pay it off yep okay
and dude i wouldn't be putting that much
money into that a 15
discount's not that much go back and
pull your company stock
and pull the charts on it and look how
much it moves in a 12-month period of
time
you'll see 15 so your little discount
could go away and evaporate in about
13 seconds so i'm not playing single
stocks
and i'm gonna use that money and get out
of debt build your emergency fund
hey thanks for the call
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
on the debt-free stage in the ramsey
solutions
lobby tori and kayla are with us hey
guys how are you
hey how's it going welcome welcome where
are y'all from
oh welcome to nashville very cool and
all the way up here to do a debt
free screen got it how much have you
paid off
140 590 dollars and 88 cents
well done how long did that take uh
three years 11 months
wow and your range of income during that
time started at about
90 and we got it all the way up to uh
175
that last year wow that's impressive
so what kind of debt was the 141 000
mostly student loans uh we had about 120
in student loans
and the rest was just miscellaneous
credit cards
car personal loans and stuff yeah yeah
you were just normal
how old are you guys i'm 32 i'm 30. okay
how long you been married
four years almost five years in june
yeah okay
faster than that man so this started
this started
uh right after you got married then yeah
yes right after yeah so what was the
story
what got you going well back in college
uh one of my roommates he gave me your
book
and so i read it fastest book i ever
read and uh
i was just fired up after that and so i
come to her
i can't remember if it was immediately
after i read it but
sometime i came to her like man look at
this we got to do this we're going to do
this and she's
kind of like yeah
i always planned on doing that so after
that we just we got started a couple
months after
i read the book put a plan in place and
got started so you got married and went
after it yep
and really didn't have to talk anybody
into it didn't have to talk about it she
was just waiting for you to come to your
senses i guess so
yep exactly man well done you guys my
college roommates didn't give me books
they gave me all kind of other stuff and
not books good for you man it's funny
because when i opened the book
he had question marks everywhere as if
he was questioning everything you said
you're studying finance so i guess ah
okay yeah well finance professors either
love me or they hate me yeah
and so they uh they um well anyway we'll
move on from that so what do you guys do
for a living
i'm a speech therapist yeah and now
during that four years i was a teacher
but um now i'm self-employed
okay cool i love your sweatshirts did
you have those made or is that a thing i
don't know about
be intentional yeah my mom made them be
intentional yep
okay because it's all about this journey
you've been on there that's it
no one wins by accident not at all it's
an intentional series of steps and
you've been doing it for three years and
11 months
and that's just poured over into
everything in our lives you know
from work to our marriage just doing
everything on purpose
you gotta do everything on purpose it's
just been our motto i like that
yep doing everything on purpose wow
that's so good
you guys well i just saw the thing flash
up on youtube so you got several of
these t-shirts
yeah yeah i thought i saw a picture fly
by okay there it is
yeah okay yeah good that's that you may
have a whole clothing line going here
for you know it
i'm gonna go buy one after the show i
like that there you go i like that
very cool well done you guys all right
how many of your peers your friend group
coming straight out of college getting
married thought you were nuts
and how many of them are cheering you on
they didn't really say if they thought
we were nuts they weren't that brave
they didn't but but i don't i don't
think it was that i think you know
everybody for the most part was very
supportive
um which helped us out because we wanted
to
do the things they were doing and you
know buy the house straight out of
college
like that but you know but you didn't we
didn't we rented
we're still renting we're in the process
of buying our first home now so yeah
good for you
it was it was it was hard but you know
i think for the most part they were
pretty supportive they didn't tell us if
they weren't
what about you kayla are you getting
good stories on that i don't think so
yeah everyone was really supportive um
yeah there's no one who was like what in
the world we don't think
this is the right thing to do did he do
it
did either of you ever have moments
where the other one had to
pick pick you up because it was getting
hard man i really need another car or i
really
want to go out tonight uh our cars our
cars just started on
cars man it got to the point where i was
like man
forget this and that's part of the story
where we had the one of the most
important things i think was
you know we have to really define our
why because our why is what really kept
us going
and what's your why our why you know
change our family tree
when i read that book you know i saw
what could be
and it just sparked hope and like you
said hope deferred makes the heart sick
and we were
we once you have hope anything's
possible and i feel like we're
unstoppable we're unstoppable now we can
do anything i feel like we do anything
you definitely are you know so wow well
done
way to go you guys very cool excellent
work excellent work okay what's the
story on this income going from 90 to
175
in three years yeah well we were like i
said we were teachers i was
we were both in education and uh i
started uh there's an online platform
for freelance work
so it's an app you can just go on and
yeah hire anybody you want for anything
so i started
doing everything you could on there like
tackle or something like that
exactly it's just like that it's called
taskrabbit so you know i was
scrubbing toilets i was move
i was i'm showing grind painting i was
doing everything i could
what was the thing you did that made the
most money for the shortest time when i
was first started it was cleaning
which i wish it wasn't but that's what
it was
but now i do a lot of mounting tvs and
uh yeah a year and a half ago i didn't
know how to do any of it my dad he's uh
you know he's got his own home repair
business so he's taught me a lot in
youtube
okay if i didn't know how to do it i
youtubed it okay and then you go and act
like you knew how and did it exactly
all right i like that that's gutsy man
that's exactly right
and i know you've missed being in the
classroom this past year huh
oh my gosh wow it's been a tough year
for teachers huh it's been tough i
had some of my teacher friends they just
told me you got it at the right time
mm-hmm
it's been real tough and speech
pathology that's a tough gig
man working with little ones elementary
man i've got the kind of like a teacher
it's also rewarding though isn't it
you're changing family trees there too
yeah absolutely
yeah that's so important i miss my kids
but you know yeah i think i'm gonna stay
what i'm doing
yeah well you're killing it you guys are
doing so good so what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is you
did it you paid off 141
dollars in three years and eleven months
be intentional
basically i like the shirt dave yeah i
think the main thing is
you gotta you you know we we talk we
dream all the time
i mean our date nights was riding around
neighborhoods and houses that we wanted
to live in
and we still do it to this day i like
that you know so
dairy queen who was earlier that's our
dave ramsey dead okay hey dip cones baby
all day
so but yeah just i think having your why
like i said earlier you
you got to have a why and um it has to
be defined in hd like chris hogan says
and and i got got up on the fridge
and just reminding yourself all the time
because it gets not if it gets hard when
it gets hard it's going to get hard
very hard i'm not gonna lie sucked
winning is not hard the price you pay to
win is what's hard yeah exactly it
sucked
but that's excellent you know we just
kept reminding ourselves of that why and
stayed with it
i love the driving around looking at
houses you want to be in some day yep
the together together doing that
together yeah and that that's a big deal
that's kind of like you know like chris
hogan talks about dreaming in hd
that's it and there it is right there 3d
hd in front of you you know it's real
it's really happening so well well done
we got a copy of chris's book for you
every day millionaires that is the next
chapter in your story without a doubt
absolutely very very well done tori and
kayla dallas texas
141 000 paid off in three years 11
months making 90 to 175 the key
is be intentional count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream
three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
coming out of school the first thing
they do the first order of business
is set this pattern in their
relationship that's gonna
work in every other area of their
relationship going forward
they set a success pattern up here it's
unbelievable and i did the exact i got
out of school and was
in more debt after my first year of
working than before because i wasn't
intentional i was an idiot and i was
trying to keep up with the joneses
i don't even want to talk about it i got
you beat so there you go not these guys
these guys are rock stars not tori and
kayla on purpose boom
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how would you like to work on something
that causes
torya and kayla to be able to change
their lives that's what we do here at
ramsey solutions we transform
lives we want to transform so many that
disruption starts spreading like
wildfire across our country
imagine a day where it's weird to have a
student loan where it's
weird to borrow money to buy a car where
the credit card has been declared the
cigarette of the financial industry
where you do work that you love where
you know how to
get along and do relationships because
dr john dolone has
intersected with his information your
life and it's changed everything
imagine being part of causing that level
of disruption
with the work you do well that's what we
do we got about a thousand folks here we
are adding 360 this calendar year
we're just finishing up another building
next door to put everybody in
and if you want to join this crusade
we're currently on the hunt for software
engineers
ruby on rails java c-sharp front-end
technologies
ux designers seo folks content folks
marketing specialists digital marketing
specialists
and a lot of other stuff if you are a
senior developer
i can promise you we want to talk to you
we want to talk to everybody though
if you want to find out about the jobs
that are available and you want to do
work that actually matters and you want
to actually go home
at six o'clock or five o'clock rather
than work 80 hours a week
we don't work 80 hours a week we go home
with our families
find out about the jobs available at
daveramsey.com click the dave's hiring
tab on the right hand side of the page
that just reminded me man when i was a
kid in college i used to tell us you
know eighty percent of
the jobs that y'all will work one day
don't exist yet
all those things you just settled off
you don't know what they even are
right and i only know what they are in
the last 36 months
so because i've had to learn as the ceo
otherwise
because i was like we're paying 225 000
a year for what exactly
for you something
and so you start finding out oh that's
what they do
yeah okay i get that that makes sense
wow
open phones here at triple eight eight
two five five
two two five john is with us john is in
san diego
hi john how are you
hi how's it going dave and john it's a
pleasure to talk with you guys
you too what's up um
so my mother is getting
what would you call it a um a gift from
my grandmother selling her
house and she's about to receive
probably around 150 000
and she wants to use that to buy a house
here and
basically the problem is my father's
kind of hesitant because he's been
burned in the past
um we lost their house back in the 08
crisis
and he's just afraid of like uh
basically
something happening in the future and
not being able to uh
hold on to the house basically that's
understandable
so what's the question um so i so um he
actually wants
me to co-sign with him because my mother
is actually getting back to work
um he feels that his credit isn't
up to up to a certain amount that would
get him the loan
even with the 20 yeah no
yeah no way no you don't co-sign for
anyone ever
think about what you just asked you
asked
my dad is so scared that something bad
is going to happen again
that this time he wants to attach me to
it
right yeah because that's why i wasn't
sure about doing that yeah no you're
super sure you know
it's just hard when your dad says hey
man i'm so scared that i'm going to
drown i want to chain myself to you so
if i drown you john too how about that
and i know that's not what he's saying
at all but it is actually what he's
saying that's what he's done
that's what he's going to do it's not
what he meant so the answer is no
yeah it is not good for him and it's not
good for you to co-sign
if they are not in a position to buy a
home they need to do the things they
need to do to get in a position to buy a
home now
we can alleviate your dad's fears
of buying a home and something bad
happening you're not going to lose your
home
your own it's very rare for you to lose
your home if you have an emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses
and you have no other debt but the home
and you buy a home where the payments no
more than a fourth of your take-home pay
on a 15-year fixed rate
now those are ramsay guidelines on
buying a home
if he does all of that which i suspect
since his credit sucks that he has debt
and he has some outstanding bad debt
doesn't he
actually he's getting out of baby step
two i think he only owes about three
thousand dollars on his car
okay then he had some old bad done okay
he did
yeah he had some back back taxes and
yeah
other debt is that and that's all paid
now
yes that's good that's great well let's
get through six months of expenses built
up or hold that back out of the 150
one of the two and it's okay if he sits
there and rents for uh six months to a
year with absolutely zero debt except
that rental
his credit will start to heal
but i would never i never tell anyone to
cosign
i i have cosigned for people and had the
opportunity to pay the bill the reason
a bank wants a cosigner is because they
don't think the main signer is going to
pay
it's always a signal to me when a when a
business
that tells me loaning money i won't take
your money yeah
right i love loaning money but not to
this guy without your help
right so that instead of it being an
insult it should be a signal right
there you go that's it and and it's
you're not being disloyal to your dad as
a matter of fact
quite the contrary you're being loyal to
him because here's what's going to
happen
you're going to move on with your last
five or six years they're going to move
on everything's going to be okay
you're on the stinking loan and you
decide it's time to buy a house because
you got married or you and your wife
currently go decide to buy a house
and guess what you can't cause you have
this contingent liability called a
co-signature on his
it's going to bring you down keep you
from buying a house or every time he
pays late you know what it does it dings
your credit
or he gets sick and can't work and
suddenly you are having to work to pay
his
house payment because it's your house
payment because you
signed for it too proverbs 13 is not
proverbs 13
17 proverbs 17 18
says one lacking incense
cosigns for another that's the new king
james version
if you read the contemporary english
version it says
it is stupid to cosign it's exactly what
it says
i thought that was the dave ramsey no
it's a contemporary english version it's
a real version of the bible
it says it's stupid to cosign yeah
because of the whole premise is you're
going to end up paying it
i don't know i don't know a family that
doesn't have
some sort of discord in it because
somebody signed for a student loan
somebody
borrowed money from their borrow money
from grandpa whatever i mean this is
this this in this incestuous handling of
money
is uh it's it's just a disaster please
don't do it john i know you're i know
i know you want to do good by your dad
but just smile be kind be love and say
dad i love you
i love you and i want good things for
you i'm
and and me being on this loan is not a
good thing for you or me
um i'm going to be your biggest
cheerleader i'm so proud of what you've
done getting these debts paid off and
being on baby step two
encouraging but don't co-sign for him
and parents that would agree that would
be the same thing for your children kids
in those that said no
but the opposite is don't co-sign for
your kids to get a house no
you know i'm trying to help my baby in a
house yeah
leave your grown children to be grown
yes
it's an it's a novel idea a helicopter
and so so i have you have heard this
term i was speaking
coleman and i were talking about this
yesterday i guess i've got a friend that
works
in educa in the education field coaching
school administrators and and
teachers and so on and she said you were
at dinner she was telling she said you
know there's all these new terms now
she said you know what a helicopter
parent is oh yeah i know i definitely
know what helicopter they'd fly in
you know pick up you know take care of
everything yeah she said do you know
what a lawnmower parent is
do you no i do not i've not heard that
what is that not it's a true thing
though huh
what is it they cut the grass out in
front of them
so that they don't have any hard times
assuring that they will never know how
to handle
hard times not if assuring they never
know how to walk through tall grass
wow no i've never heard that before
that's lawnmower parents
lawnmower parents are the next step
after you're a helicopter parent and
it's continuing to deteriorate
so the great the greatest these are all
these great phrases for codependent
the greatest parenting thing was my wife
i went to help
hank i know him to fall down and she
said he's gonna fall down
once and that was the greatest like let
him fall
then he won't climb back up on that
anymore oh she's so wise
tough that puts this hour the ramsay
show in the books
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today he's the guy
that does the dr john dolone show oddly
enough and
uh it's a wonderful podcast that is
exploding where we deal with your issues
about life relationships mental health
challenges
boundaries family things it's all woven
in together
and guess what it's all woven in
together here at
on the ramsay show as well and always
has been for the last 30 years so it's
perfect that he's here to help the phone
number here is triple eight eight two
five five two two five you've got
questions for dr john
and or me we will definitely both jump
in triple
eight eight two five five two two five
mark's with us in seattle hey mark how
are you
hey good gentlemen how are you guys
doing great man what's up
uh first off just wanted to give you
guys thanks for uh you know everything
that you guys do
uh my parents are big rambears they went
through your class through church and
all that
they just kind of taught me everything
and i pass along my brother-in-law's who
are
big listeners i'm sure they're even
listening now just had a
quick question for you i'm getting out
of the military here soon within the
next year
a lot of baby steps four and five right
now i have two kids and all that
i got about 15k in the savings uh and
when i get out we're looking at moving
back home to
florida or home for us uh back to
florida
the question with that is my wife is
able to transfer
she's a government contractor she makes
uh
between 20 and 25 000 a year
but i don't know what i'm going to do
yet and so we're trying to figure out
when we go back to florida if it would
be smart
for us to you know finally
get the house that we've wanted we've
been nothing but renters
our entire life finally get uh get the
house
we want or should we continue renting
until i can find a nice steady job um
and basically go from there
you're not gonna get the house you want
with twenty five thousand dollar year
income yeah did you say she makes 25
grand a year
or 125 yeah uh 25 25 grand a year we got
about 15 000 in savings this is
my man yeah i wouldn't even transfer
just go get a job at starbucks make 25
grand
okay yeah so no no you don't you don't
have enough income to buy a house that
you're going to be pleased with
okay and so i have the gi bill that uh
doesn't matter they don't they don't
give you houses they don't qualify you
for houses under the va
for that you can't afford okay
we'll if i went that route we'd still be
getting uh
i'd be getting about 1600 a month for
the housing allowance uh as well as
me working either part-time if we go
that route oh wait wait a minute
you're talking about the gi you're not
talking about the gi bill to buy a house
you're talking about you're going back
to school
yeah oh and you're one you want to take
the stipend and do that on top of hers
no you need to you need to rent until
you're out of school yeah
runs until i'm out of school yeah what
are you going to study
uh right now i'm just working on my uh
just general associates and then from
there i got a couple of different things
i'm looking at
uh possible uh looking at nursing degree
um my eyes are kind of open right now uh
i'm kind of getting out of the military
earlier than i expected
okay so we're just kind of open anything
right now
thank you for your service and you have
this wonderful benefit to have education
at your fingertips
education with no game plan as to where
it's going to take you
is known as a waste of time
so you need to spend the next few months
dialing in
a detailed career path and game plan
that then will tell you what kind of
education you need to get you may not
need a four-year degree you may want to
go into technology and get some
microsoft certs
i don't know i don't know what you're
going to do you may want to go in the
real estate business in which case you
don't need a four-year degree you need a
real estate license i don't know what
you're going to do with your life
but you need to dial that in and don't
just go to school because it's there
that's going to take you nowhere john's
got a phd
in higher education am i wrong no i do
and i've worked with veterans for years
who
they get out and then they come and they
just start going to school and think
they're going to figure it out on the
way
and then you you know those that are
dialed in and there is man there are a
few students
as as that you want in your class more
than a dialed in veteran who knows what
they're going after it's got a game plan
thank goodness for this benefit that i
think they they fully deserve
but yeah i'd rather see you go work for
a year go be a nurse's aide go work in a
hospital go do something and see is this
what i want to do
don't want to dedicate the next four to
six years of my life doing this you do
not have to go straight into school out
of the military
okay in order to you know it does it
does not invalidate your gi bill
right and yeah the only the only thing
is uh trying to
set up something uh like i said i had
the two kids and all that so we're gonna
need that
some type of income uh coming in and her
uh
her salary isn't gonna really cut it
that's right that's exactly that's what
my point is and so buying a house is
down the road
yeah your big the big thing in front of
you
is to you know you got you got one year
so let's set some deadlines and say 90
days from today
we will have spent enough time in prayer
in discussion and reading and learning
and uh visiting some people that are in
different career fields that's right
talking to real cr you know reading
everything ken coleman writes
uh and learning about careers and where
you're going to go to have dialed in
and then you say i've got nine months to
get prepared to
start knocking out the things that are
that are going to allow me to go be one
of those
after you've decided what one of those
is
go do that be one of those then talk
about buying a house
how many people over the years dave have
you talked to veterans who come in
and they get that house-buying
quote-unquote benefit
then they find themselves stuck i used
to live
one of the colleges i worked at was next
to a base and it just felt like there
was a rotation
they got a stipend to live off base and
they just go by a house and then in two
years they're getting shipped out
somewhere getting sent out yeah it's a
mess
they were had no money down so they're
upside down upside down yep they're
stuck just feels like people got stuck a
lot yeah
the va loan the sad thing is the va loan
for housing
is supposed to be a nice benefit now the
education loan is a nice benefit
but the va loan actually sucks oh yeah
for two reasons one is it's actually
more expensive
it's a higher interest rate and higher
fees which is absolutely
ridiculous you would think that if
you're going to give the veterans a
benefit that it would be
cheaper it would be better than
everybody that's right it's not so there
you go there's your veterans
administration working for you
but then the uh uh the second thing is
is they do have this zero down idea
which means the seller pays all the
closing costs you literally can walk in
and sign the papers with not
a dollar and buy a house but you can
never walk out that back door
again exactly but then you owe 100
more than 100 by the time all the
stuff's rolled into the thing
of what the house is actually worth you
know how long it takes to get out of
that
five to seven years before you've got
enough equity to sell it and break even
and that geez louise yeah this is it's a
nightmare it's a trap
you know don't step there it's gonna rip
your leg off and i know you want to come
home get plugged in get a house
get those kids everything's stable just
hang it there man hang in there
va didn't mean for that to be a trap
they were trying to be nice but nothing
down is not nice
nothing down screws you over and at a
higher interest rate than you could have
gotten if you put down a good down
payment
so no you don't want that benefit you're
right it's a strap
it's a trip this is the ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
here on the ramsey show the phone number
is triple eight eight
two five five two two five well folks
2020 was crazy
and your 2020 taxes are gonna be crazy
so uh first you need to you know some of
you got unemployment did you know that's
taxable by the way
yes that's taxable income um another big
thing to keep in mind was remote working
if you left your resident state to work
remotely from another state you may have
to pay taxes in two different
states how joyful is that come on man
well not always the case it depends on
the state you live in depends on the
state you worked in and if you lived and
worked in different states you need to
look into state taxes and you know how
this works
it's complicated if you're unsure if
2020 has made your taxes different
take our tax quiz it's free
it'll tell you if your situation is
simple enough to do with tax software
or if you're better off hiring a pro
text
the word tax quiz to 33789 and you'll
find out what your tax situation really
looks like
will help guide you and we can hook you
up with the best the ramsey smart tax
software
or with one of the elps for taxes the
pros whatever we need to do to help you
we're going to help you
text tax quiz no spaces
to 33789
and just so people know that's the tax
stuff i'm using for my taxes for my
family
it's great man just like that charles is
in toledo
hey charles how are you i am
great uh glad that i found you on the
radio mostly
i'm sorry on on my heart actually a
friend of mine
years ago introduced me to some of your
methods
not to you so that kind of slowed my
progress down a lot i could have been
doing a lot more sooner but i
am uh 50 um pretty much debt free except
for mortgage
and when i start putting in
it's a zero percent mortgage so it kind
of doesn't make sense to really save a
lot of money to skip the 401k to pay
that off
but i can do that but so the point is
um does
the financial peace university or the
dam
ramsey plus teach me
how much of my money i can spend
where for example i like to take my wife
and kids out to
dinner but i don't know i can't find
online how much am i allowed to allocate
towards that per
month i'm a late saver uh just you know
i only have about 20 000
in my roth ira at the moment
so i do want to put in as much as i can
in july i'm eligible for a rough
401k but they will match seven percent
so i want to do that
that's great well budget percentages
would change
depending on your situation if you're in
what we call baby step two
meaning you're clearing off all your
debts except your home and i think
that's where you said you are
you know if you're already past baby
step two then
uh you know yes you can allocate some
you can lighten up your percentages and
allocate some for fun
some for restaurants and vacations and
those kinds of things
if you are in the get out of debt mode
gazelle intensity and baby step two the
the allocated percentage for restaurants
is zero
the allocated percentage for vacation is
zero while you work your way out of debt
and it's not like dave ramsey's
punishing somebody like some of these
idiots say on social media
but it's more like uh this is how you
win right
you have to pay a price to get out of
debt it's how i won you have to pay a
price to get out of debt it's not easy
it's hard
now but but as you go along yes there
are some
uh guidelines we've got some percentages
some of them are in the back of the
different books
in uh for instance total money makeover
i think there's a
percentage guidelines on the in the
forms
section in the back of the book they'll
analog forms i don't think there are
percentages
in every dollar if i remember in the
budgeting
app which is really what i recommend you
use but if you're just looking for some
guidelines
there's that now one that is well known
as we tell folks not to have
more than 25 of your income take home
pay
going out in housing your house payment
and uh so there you are uh but
you know what what ends up happening is
this the percentages don't matter as
much as
every dollar that goes to one thing
can't go to another
and once you start doing that with your
spouse then you say then
you come to an agreed amount for
restaurants right and it's you know
and so if you make 70 000 a year the
agreed amount for restaurants is not
700 a month right because you can't hit
your other goals
and you're going to make those decisions
automatically when you're looking at it
um but there's not a magic formula that
says you know if you just limit your
restaurants to this
but but instead you start making wise
decisions that everything
every budget category is a trade-off
putting money in one
by definition means there's no money for
the other one and i like what rachel
talks about is asking yourself that next
layer which is
why are you buying that are you buying
another shirt do you have
money in your clothing budget because
you actually need new clothes great
are you buying stuff new clothes because
you're that's that's your addiction
right yeah that is
a way you're wallpapering over some some
other stuff you'd be dealing with
so i like to ask myself and the eating
out thing is that that's right it's not
for showing off for other people but
you know why are we eating out so much
right is it because we don't like
spending time at home
is because one of us doesn't want to
cook or doesn't like to cook or we can't
get to the store or is it just because
at the end of the day we just it's a
form of entertainment that's right
you know and so are we you know what's
going on with that why is it why are we
doing that
doug's with us in tampa hey doug welcome
to the ramsay show
hi mr ramsey i'm dr john i'm a little
nervous
but um here it goes okay
uh um a wonderful woman a few months ago
after moving down here from pittsburgh
and um
there's a large gap in our income where
i'm at about 60
000 and she makes about 175 000
has a house that's valued at over 400
000 dollars
she sounds like a wonderful woman
[Laughter]
she is she is and she's listening at
home working
and you know i've been down this road
before
in 2010 met somebody and
uh married her and nine months later
i was diagnosed with leukemia however in
the meantime
we were trying to buy a house and i had
no credit
and in order to get approved for a
mortgage
i had to take out credit cards long
story short
three and a half years later she
divorced me before my cancer treatments
were over
and i i ended up moving into my own
place
wow how can we best help you today doug
okay well how do i i see a future with
this woman
but i've tried to convince her if she
gives me a hundred thousand dollars i'll
give her
two percent cash back and she says well
i won't have things
but if you're so confused why would she
give you a hundred thousand dollars
well for credit cards she's she likes to
use credit card stuff oh
you know and i'm saying you know you
talk about that
yeah the metaphor i thought you just met
a girl like hey babe
give me a hundred thousand dollars yeah
that's a problem so
okay here's the thing the number one
cause of divorce in north america
today's money fights and money problems
and
john will tell you an all good phds in
psychology will tell you you're not
really fighting about money you're
really fighting about what's important
to you power
control control life options margins
and so um until you guys can work your
way through this and get on the same
page about money
the relationship is stalled right
and she's not better than you because
she makes more money than you and
you are not better than her because of
feeling like y'all got to come at this
at equals who cares who's making the
most money right now right or or what
the
really what the past is that's right the
pass just makes you want to address it
right which is a good thing but um
if you can agree on your money
principles and on your spending
you are agreeing about your whole
freaking life right because those things
flow around it
and and when you cannot then you know
you're stalled until you can
and so i would recommend you guys jump
in you can jump in and go through ramsey
plus jump in there together and start
taking some of the classes together it
gives you a point of reference to talk
through some of these things
and you know as this goes forward you
may want to do some pre-marriage
counseling that will get you there as
well
don't marry someone that you're not on
the same page with about money
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now we love doing debt-free screams on
the ramsey show
we particularly love doing debt-free
screams live
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage
we really love doing debt-free screams
on the
in the lobby on the debt-free stream
stage when it's one of our own ramsey
team members
and kate cameron is with us on the stage
and half the dadgum building is out here
to watch to cheer her on to do her
debt-free
scream there's hundreds of people out
here this is a little nervous
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
we're up here doing a world-class radio
show there's about three people milling
around out here you walk up here and the
whole blaze shuts down that comes out
here
a lot of support that's for sure very
cool very cool how much debt you paid
off kate
25 564 cool how long did this take
12 months 12 months i will not ask your
income because your
peers are standing around and that would
be unfair
so what kind of debt was the 26 000
it was all student loans all right very
cool
very cool okay so now you've been with
us about what three years
it'll be two uh next week okay all right
two years and you're in the ramsey
education department meaning you work
with the high schools and the k-12 right
yes i do and what do you do there so i
talk with our teachers and
administrators
and i get them to have our curriculum
for the students yeah be able to teach
foundations and personal finance
exactly some of the 48 of the high
schools in america that teach it
and you're it's all your fault well done
well done so you've been here for two
years and it sounds like you've been
working on this
process about that period of time then
so does the story have something to do
with joining us and so you're like oh i
guess i better do this stuff
yeah so um when i first moved down here
i was really excited
and a funny story you know i had my car
break down before i moved down here from
michigan
so i was like you know what i love this
job i'm meant to be here i know i
am so i moved into an apartment right
next to the old building actually so i
walked to work
walked to the grocery store for about
three months and then i was really
thankful like while i was saving up
i had my family friend just gift me a
car
so it's just one of those things that
things just work in your favor
when you're following god right and so
after taking fpo i was like i really
need to be doing this i need to be doing
it the right way
and so i finally decided after actually
taking it twice
to just say i'm going to be gazelle
intense so my 2020 goal is i'm i'm debt
free
that's my 2020 goal and you did it
during the pandemic then
yes of course your pay didn't stop here
so that didn't that
that wasn't interrupted but uh our lives
were all turned upside down anyway
yeah so how old are you i'm 26. okay so
who were your biggest cheerleaders
uh definitely my friends my family and
of course my team as you can see
yeah absolutely cool so mom and dad
where where did you move from to move
here uh mid michigan
okay so they're back home cheering you
on then huh yes yes
very cool so what was the hardest part
of this i mean working in ramsay's hard
anyway because we work our butts off
yeah and this stuff's like all over you
and then
you know you're like smothered with it
right right well i think the hardest
part for me to even get started was
i had a very like anxious money
classroom as we teach from rachel's book
right
and so i was so afraid to spend
thousands of dollars paying off my
student loan debt because i'm like i
need this money right and was used to a
very like paycheck to paycheck kind of
um you know classroom like that anxious
classroom and so
um it was after i went through fpu that
i'm like listen i need to be doing this
i know i can do it i have a stable
income like there's no excuse
so i think the hardest part when i was
actually in the journey was saying like
i know i can do this i'm gonna do my
discipline
god's gonna provide and just continue to
get excited about the process so you
were your neck deep in it
and then we uh we put everybody in the
auditorium downstairs
covet hits and we said okay um here's
what we're going to do everybody
we're going to start working from home
and if we don't keep revenues up it's
not going to go well
right and you know leadership won't take
pay first
but eventually if we don't get revenue
in this place it's going to cost
start costing people jobs you know i
made that announcement
and you're sitting there pouring all
your money onto debt
and gave all your savings up you had to
be freaking out
yeah a little bit and i'm in a sales
role so of course that's always
uncertainty but i had faith in god and i
was at the time working at um like
part-time for a catering company serving
there
and of course with catering companies
it's usually like big events weddings
that kind of thing
and so that ended too so it was like
okay one thing after another
but um i found another job serving and
bartending
and i was like i'm gonna put my work in
and god will provide
and he did and i'm really thankful to be
here and
of course sales went down because the
school administrators weren't there to
buy curriculum for
from you and then they came back up
right
yeah so it's turned out okay by the end
of the year but it's been quite a roller
coaster you went through emotionally
while you did this i'm so proud of you
thank you that was tough yeah and you're
coming to work every day your job was to
talk to people who were completely
frazzled all day long too
and i talk a lot about secondary
traumatic stress you experience that
tell me about that
yeah um daily i would have teachers be
like i don't even know what's going on i
don't know about curriculum i don't know
about anything and i'm like okay we're
gonna make it through guys
like i promise it'll be okay one way or
another we're gonna get these students
through
so so every every day every week you are
talking to frazzled people on top of
your frazzled world right and going home
saying
i'm doing the right thing i'm balling
the plan i'm falling apart good scott's
got my back guys
got my back exactly yeah well done kate
thanks very well done you're tough
you are tough so so there's a 26 year
old out there that
owes 25 30 40 000
and they're just not all in explain the
feeling
just throughout your body explain this
to folks what this feels like now now
that you're free
yeah it is just so fun to be like okay
i just got a paycheck and i have options
like
i of course i'm saving right baby step
three but um
it's like okay i don't need to put it
towards my student loans i don't need to
put it towards this thing that i owe
like i have
options and that freedom and that
ability to say i get to choose what i
get to do with this is so worth it
100 times it was worth a really tough
hard scratch and claw year
absolutely yeah the price you paid was
worth it
exactly you ever go back in debt no oh
my gosh
no no that's scary it's like oh
no sorry i i love my options and kate
you are tough
and you man you went step by step but i
don't want the people listening to this
and you can't see it but man you are
surrounded by people and we cannot do
life by ourselves and you've got
cheerleader after cheerleader after
chile in this room and so
everybody's here sharing in this this
extraordinary achievement man it's
awesome
well done so well done so proud of you
all right it is kate from the education
solutions team
where she calls chur or calls churches
calls schools and
administrators and teachers every day to
get them to teach the
high school curriculum foundations and
personal finance because don't you wish
you had learned this stuff when you were
a kid
it's almost our byline over there you
know and uh
highly successful and this is what you
call an incredible 26 year old right
here
we got a building full of these they're
incredible incredible they're incredible
so proud of you so well done all right
kate
26 000 paid off in 12 months
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one i'm debt-free
[Applause]
yeah baby
yeah you know people don't understand
that have never led an organization
that during the pandemic those of us
that were leading companies
yeah we're looking out at a room full of
her
yeah going it's my job yeah as the
leader to keep the revenue coming in so
she gets to live her dream
yeah and i'm sitting here thinking all
that stress we went through last year in
leadership
yeah to be able to keep this place
afloat be able to keep things running
all the criticism we took
that's why we did it that's right for
her because she keeps her job that's
right
and she gets to do this i'm so proud of
her
that is so cool man and she didn't cave
in she didn't quit she didn't say well
i'll try again in 2021
yeah she didn't panic yeah she played
through
act of faith walked out her faith kept
making the calls what a cool 26 year old
it's awesome
very cool got a building full of them
man i love it this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
thank you for joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five donna's in utica
new york hi donna how are you
hi dave i'm doing well how are you
better than i deserve what's up
okay so i have a whole life insurance
policy
um and i i would like to cash it in
i just found out that there's dividends
on the policy which i believe are
tax-free
um i have a loan out on the policy
and a cash value on the policy a small
cash value so my question is
should i take out the dividends first or
if i cash it in will i get those
dividends that i have on my policy
you should get them if they haven't been
used to buy paid up
editions yeah they have not i didn't
even realize that
they would have just have been added to
your cash value
what's that i'm sorry it would have just
been added to your cash value and none
of this is going to be taxable
so they're saying i got forty three
hundred dollars in dividends
and a cash value of fifty three hundred
dollars but
then they said i'm going to be capital
gains
tax on 80s no no
okay i doubt it so here here's
here's how the calculation works okay
the dividends are not taxable period
okay how much is your loan
the loan is 15 000. i just okay so
these numbers are above the loan being
paid back right
yeah okay because you don't get the loan
money
i mean you get you gotta the money has
the cash value has to pay off the loan
first so right now as far as the cash
value whether it has a capital gains or
not here's the basis
all the money you've ever paid into this
policy
added together is your basis
so do you remember what your premium is
forty dollars a month
okay for how long have you been doing
this
uh 1992. so
500 bucks a year for 30 years
you don't have any capital gains
30 times 500 all right is more than
your cash value you would only have a
you would only have a capital
gain is if all the premiums you have
paid in
over time um is equal to
more than your cash value
or less than your cash value and it
never is because these things suck so
bad
they're horrible i know okay now let me
tell you how
a dividend works just for the fun of it
okay now how old are you
60. okay do you need life insurance
is someone count on your income to eat
no are you married yeah
okay do you all have a pile of money
other than this
well i mean i have and we have savings
but
i mean i probably only have about ten
thousand dollars in savings
so how does he eat if you die
well he's working and has a retirement
okay
all right so if you don't need life
insurance then it's fine if you want to
buy some life insurance
you would buy it prior to canceling this
that's thing one
now a dividend is not taxable
because it is not a dividend
in the true sense of the word a dividend
is when a company
makes a profit like home depot and they
pay their stockholders some of the
profit out
and that's a dividend okay life
insurance dividends
have nothing to do with that at all
there are two kinds of companies in the
life insurance world stock company and a
participating company
stock company never pays dividends the
only ones that do are participating
the stockholders of a participating
company are the policyholders
so if you have a state farm policy or
you have a
i don't know what who's whose is yours
with credential yeah prudential's
participating okay
and that means that the policy holders
are the owners now in order for them to
give you
an owner profit back
they would have had to charge you extra
to create that profit does that make
sense
yes so there's no dividend if you're if
i own the company
and i want to and i want to buy
something from myself
and i charge myself a little extra so
that i can give myself back some more
money that's nice of you
that's nice of me and then so that's why
the irs has deemed
life insurance policies that have
dividends to be non-taxable because the
the actual ruling states it's the return
of a deliberate overcharge right
okay and that's why it's not taxable
it's a it's a shell game it's a scam
and so uh it's of no benefit at all so
that that's just
all that is is you paid too much for the
policy all these years so now you got 4
000 of it coming back
that's all that was right then on top of
that you paid too much to build up a
cash value
and you're going to get that back but
you're not even getting back all that
you paid in so you've got no taxes on
that either
so that that's the moral of the story on
that and and these whole lot that's you
know
one more way that these holiday
or one more way that these uh whole life
policies suck
it's just unbelievable and by the way
you paid extra to create the
savings account in there call cash value
and when you wanted your money out you
had to go borrow
your own money and pay them interest to
do that so that loan you've been paying
interest on was where you borrowed your
own money
in this whole time do these companies
take that money
and then they go invest it somewhere
else and keep the gap right oh yeah
yeah yeah absolutely so they're like a
long-term interest-free bank
virtually interested in making money on
their stuff right that's why
you know that's why in any skyline in
america
you know you drive around there are two
tall buildings
banks and life insurance companies right
you built them people
wow you built them in both cases you
gave them your money
and uh you know this is the great the
great credit card scam
the great you know car loan scam uh the
great the great
whole life life insurance scam and uh
some of the wealthiest companies in
america are life insurance companies
because they have all of the money like
hers sitting on the books
in the commercial real estate business
if you want to go get a shopping mall
for uh 26 million dollars and you want
to bought you want to find a lender for
that
the primary lender is life insurance
companies
they do functioning as their own bank
insiders they do
tons of commercial lending and they're
lending her money
and they make the spread and they make
the spread that's right
wow just follow the money baby
just follow the money and you'll see
where it is you'll see what's been going
on
so oh man and i've never heard that
you get the blessing of them increasing
your rate
and then saying hey here you go here's
some of it back look how
look how benevolent yeah right yeah wow
so you know if as long as your cash
value now if her cash value does include
her
more her loan amount so shh
i'm gonna rethink that she probably had
about a fifteen thousand dollar basis
and she said she had a fifteen thousand
loans so she might actually have a cash
flow a capital gain
you'd have to see your tax professional
to be sure and double check that but the
way you calculate your basis is
all the premiums you've ever paid in
is your basis and as long as your cash
value is not higher than that number
it almost never is then there is no
capital gain on it because you lost
money you lost money right
you didn't keep up with inflation
putting 40 bucks under your bed for
yeah 20 or 30 years you'd have been
better off putting it in a fruit jar
you'd end up with more money
wow at the end of this story wow you
wouldn't have the life insurance but
if you put your money in a fruit jar and
buy an inexpensive term policy you'd end
up with more money yeah if you put the
money in a real investment
like a mutual fund and buy an
inexpensive term policy
good roth ira you'd end up with millions
of dollars more
wow i mean that little 40 a month policy
would have amounted to not
you know we're talking about 8 000 15
000 here these kinds of numbers it would
have been
hundreds of thousands of dollars wow
difference
instead they loaned money to a shopping
mall developer with
her money that's how it works
oh well that's discouraging it
yeah is just you know live and learn
don't buy a whole life that's right
and if you got one get rid of it this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice dr john
dolone ramsey personality and host of
the
explodingly popular dr john dolone
podcast
i is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five you get real talk on
life relationships
mental health issues the chaos of
anxiety depression disconnection
and all kinds of just good old grandma
common sense stuff from dr john
all the time on his show and when he's
on here too so you can call in right now
triple eight eight two five
five two two five if you can't get
through today because the lines are
always pretty full around here
you can always email and participate on
john's show by emailing ask
john at ramseysolutions.com
or leave a voicemail at 844 844-693-3291
ryan starts off this hour in akron ohio
hey ryan how are you
i'm doing well how are you dave better
than i deserve what's up in your world
awesome hey well i've always enjoyed
personal financing and learning about it
and in college i've even helped friends
you know make budgets and
just basic stuff like that and i just
got so excited about it
i know i wanted to help people with
their money and i graduated this past
may may 2020
got a job at a bank because i thought
you know that's a great place to help
people with their money
and that's right around this time i
started to listen to your show
consistently
and really do the baby steps for myself
good for you
how many you yeah yeah i've seen how
many uh
lives your plan has changed dramatically
and i feel like um the stories i hear on
your show are from people who
would walk into the bank and i would
feel
pressure you know for my boss and from
corporate to
sell credit cards and sell home equity
lines of credit
i feel like i'm in this position where
i'm putting people
uh in a position to you know
come to your show like you know what i
mean like um
i just feel like i'm pushing i you know
my job is to push debt and more debt
and i'm just wondering where you know in
the financial world
can i go um where this isn't the
you know tool of
making money for companies is debt yeah
well i mean if you work in a pizza place
you're gonna be selling pizza
that's the way it works so i mean that's
um
and if you're health food nut that
probably is not gonna be right
not to be congruent right yeah so that
that's kind of where you find yourself
um a lot of people with your itch
uh gravitate towards uh
the uh the investment advisory side of
the business like our smart investor
pros
where you work for a a local
organization that is a member of a
broker dealer and you help people
get investments going and most of those
people do not peddle debt most of them
peddle investments
and they some of them go extend beyond
that into some
basic financial planning like they'll
hook you up to help you get a will or
they'll hook you up in that world they
do now
our smart mr pros generally just do
investing but the ones that we endorse
but uh
you know some of them get into that some
of them get into a little bit of
but you'll have the opportunity let's
say you had a
a client that had an investment
portfolio
that was uh 60 years old but he had a 30
year old daughter who was struggling
and brought her to you
and you could you know to help teach her
about budgeting in the process so we did
to do a lot of that kind of thing
in the crossfire like that the only
place in the banking world
where you're able to uh
where you're not forced with a quota a
boss breathing down your neck to sell
debt like you have experienced is
small town local banks community banks
aren't as aggressive
in the debt marketing and uh and credit
unions
uh that's why i endorse both both of
those and not the large mega banks
because the mega banks are pretty well
they're just pretty well debt peddlers
is what they do they just
if they figure if you're breathing you
need a bunch of their debt and um
i don't know which one you're working at
i didn't ask but the the
larger ones are much more soulless in
their approach
and you know i've got friends in the
community banking business
obviously i don't believe in borrowing
money i'll teach people borrow money but
they're much more responsible
with their interaction there's a moral
component for them with their
interaction with their customer
versus these mega banks they'll just
shovel as much down somebody's throat as
they can get in there
and and you know you're going to lose
your job if you don't sell a certain
amount of credit cards car loans and
home equity loans in your position
and i'll tell you that right the the the
30 000 foot view of your question is you
can't work very long
in a job that violates a core value of
yours
whether that's treating people
disrespectfully whether that's like dave
said peddling food that you think
is not healthy selling debt at some
point you will begin to fracture from
the inside out yeah i mean let's just
completely change the metaphor let's
pretend that you
uh that alcoholism killed your father
and you don't believe in drinking and
drinking scares your death
you'd make a horrible bartender yeah
you know and that's that's what john's
talking about is
and you don't need to quit today we're
not suggesting you run in there with
your hair on fire and make some
political statement
we're not trying to create an act make
you into an activist okay
but the uh uh but you long term what is
good for you is to find something and
that's why
that's what that's the itch you've got
that's what you're scratching
is long long-term you need to find
something that is congruent with your
belief system and your values
you're not going to prosper otherwise
you're never going to be a really great
banker at that bank that's exactly right
and you're never going to be able to
sleep either yeah you know the ball
isn't going to be happy the customers
aren't going to be happy you're not
going to be happy
nobody's happy you're not selling enough
debt the customers are getting debt
they're not happy
you're selling debt you don't want to
sell debt you're not happy nobody's
happy here yeah you know and so
you know you're just you head on your
pillow dude and and so what i would do
is i develop a
you know like an 18-month runway or a
12-month runway that says all right i've
got to start
doing some of ken coleman's materials on
hunting for a career
thinking about a career i'm going to
investigate for instance the financial
advisory world
what's it take to get into that what
have i got to do what licensing have i
got to get what have i got to do to get
hired in that world
and begin to move in that direction but
um i i you know i i would not ask a
pizza place to not sell pizza
right and i'm not going to ask a bank to
not sell debt
i am going to ask all of you to not buy
it from them
so that you're not harmed but i'm not
going to expect an alligator to quit
biting it's what alligators do and this
is a common situation he says he just
graduated and started this job that
he wanted to help people right you have
a vision and this helps people with
money and bank's got money so i'll go
over there that's right man and but that
happens to
graduates all over the place right and
then they get in and gets you behind the
curtain see how the sausages
made see what we're actually doing here
and then they have a crisis of
value yeah right crisis of conscience
yeah it's very real
i appreciate you ryan you got a good
you're a man of integrity
and you weren't you weren't being a
drama queen about it you weren't being
crazy about it but you're just going
this just feels weird and i don't think
it's going to work and you're right it's
not
it's not going to work and they're not
going to change right so how do you
treat them with dignity and then how do
you hold your head up when you go find
something else
you know you're going to be you're going
to suck at selling debt so they're going
to be happy when you leave
[Laughter]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits secure your future today
visit nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show dr john deloney
ramsey personality is my co-host today
open phones at eight eight two five five
two two five peak real estate season is
here
if you are thinking about buying a home
this year here's a piece of simple
advice that could help
save you uh from making a six figure
mistake don't
buy something you don't understand
are you financially are you sure you're
financially ready for that mortgage
are you confused about how the buying
process works are you confused about the
mortgage
press pause and get educated before you
buy
start by checking out our new 13 step
home buying checklist it's free
you'll learn about every step in the
buying process from saving for the down
payment to the closing day
plus you'll get pro tips on how to make
smart money decisions along the way
to get this free 13-step home buying
checklist
text home checklist
no spaces home checklist
to 33789 or you can visit the
checklist and find out exactly what the
what it takes to buy the home you're
dreaming of
text home checklist to three
three seven eight nine nick is in new
york city hi nick welcome to the dave
oh to the ramsay show hey what's up
how you doing dave um i wanted to ask
you
uh i'm 22 turning 23 this year and i
wanted to start saving for my retirement
uh my company doesn't offer a 401k plan
or anything else
so i was interested in what your
thoughts are
on what kind of rra ira i should get
into a traditional one
or a roth one or something like that or
if you have a better solution i would
love to hear it
well good for you man you're welcome way
ahead of the curve to be working on this
at your age excellent
so are you out of debt uh yeah i mean
right now the only payment the only
payments i make
are on my phone watch and that's about
60 a month
okay your phone what phone watch my
my cell phone and my smart watch oh i'm
sure together they cost about 60
a month that's just the cellular service
okay yeah
and the uh and and how much money do you
have in savings
um well in my personal savings i have
like a few thousand dollars about three
thousand dollars um but when i was in
the eighth grade
i got hit by a truck so when i was 18 i
got some money from that and i
invested it in stocks about three
thousand dollars
in single stocks uh yeah and
e-trade and stuff like that okay all
right
um all right well before we move into
investing i need you to have three to
six months of
household expenses are you on your own
are you living with mom and dad
uh no i still live with my parents okay
all right
your three thousand dollars probably is
your emergency fund uh
all right to start with nick let's just
back up the first thing is i don't do
single stocks i know a lot about them
i buy i buy investments i've got
hundreds of millions of dollars of
investments
and uh but i don't buy single stocks
because i don't like the risk associated
with that
and the game you're playing there's a
lot of risk now if someone is
really loving it and you obviously have
a a knack for it and it's something you
want to fool with
no more than 10 of your net worth
so in your case about two thousand
dollars worth is about all you ought to
have in single
stocks you're taking too much risk in my
opinion
okay so i would move that towards mutual
funds
and then as far as starting qets is not
only
single stocks but it is mainly single
stocks yeah okay
and uh then the next question is when
are you planning to move out
and what money do you need to do that
um i don't really have a plan on moving
out yet i'm
still like i just started working
and i probably would want to move out
between 26 and 28
years old possibly yeah
um i'm really not i'm not really sure on
what do you mean with that yeah
what do you make uh about 15
16 000 a year i'm working in a work
study program right now yeah so i'm not
making
a lot of when will you complete the work
study program
uh a few years two years two and a half
okay
when you get your income up to where you
can i don't want you 28 years old in
your mother's basement dude
get out and get going you do not need to
start your roth iras yet you need to you
need to pile up money
to make the transition out of your
household and complete your studies and
complete your career
get your career going then you need to
start and i would start with a roth ira
in good growth stock mutual funds i love
that you're asking the question
but you're a little bit early in your
process not in your age
but in your process you're in the middle
of transit transitional things
that need to happen before you start
investing yeah
i'm just trying to wrap my head around
that spirit and also that um
it seems it just seems out of balance
you don't hear that very often that
someone's
thinking so strategically and so far
ahead
and also i'm living to my parents house
i'm about 30
28 you know what i mean so it's always
the other way around
i've got people like racing out of their
parents house the moment they can and
buying a way big too big a house or a
truck and saying hey man you gotta have
a future too so this kind of flipped
around a little bit
yeah yeah yeah get your own place nick
get your own placements
as soon as you're you know you probably
can't do that on 15k uh in new york city
okay
but when you get this work study thing
going and you can get your income coming
up in the next 12 to 18 24 months or
whatever then
let's move out get your fully funded
emergency fund at that point of three to
six months of expenses remain and stay
debt-free through that whole process and
then you would start investing
when you're stepping into your bed into
your career
and 15 of your income is what i would do
there in good mutual funds
with a good roth ira bill is with us in
dayton ohio hi
bill how are you i'm great dave how are
you doing
better than i deserve what's up oh
awesome awesome yeah i have a question
on
an inheritance um i'm based on debt free
no house payment or anything debt-free
um
i do have emergency fund of about 25 30
000 dollars
but i'm about to inherit about 440
000 dollars um yeah and it's in a uh
it's going to be in a um like a
traditional i believe traditional ira
okay an inherited ira okay yeah so i
don't know what the best
i know i think i have to take that out
you do have to begin
taking over 10 years yeah you got you
got 10 years
on the new the new laws that just passed
a year ago
and so you're going to take out a 10th a
year doesn't mean you have to take it
out and spend it but you
it's not going to be protected under the
ira and whatever you pull out is taxable
each year
no there's no penalties on it but you
can take
and you can't roll it into your own ira
you can take it out pay the taxes
and then you do whatever so 40 50 grand
a year is going to be rolling out into
your hand
and you need to decide ahead of time
after after i pay the taxes on that
what am i going to do with it and in the
meantime
it ought to be parked in you can you can
move the investments around
inside the inherited ira are is it
already in good mutual funds or do you
know
i'm not 100 sure i have to look into
that okay if i can't move it around if i
want to move it around yeah you can
you know you can move the ira to a smart
vester pro sit down with them
develop two different game plans one for
the existing pile of money
in mutual funds and two what am i gonna
do with these mandatory rollouts
these mandatory money this mandatory
money have to pull out and you can turn
around
have another investment account and it
just moves right over into that
after taxes okay you don't have to take
it home
you don't have to take it home by a
truck you know it's not required but uh
you may you may want to you may want to
do some nice things with it
you may you know there may be a few
things you want to spend some of this on
you may
be some generosity things you want to do
uh then
all that's okay it's your money okay
so it is better to take it over the
10-year period to take a little out of
the time
because of it i'm assuming it's less of
tax yes
uh the the um
the because all that money that is tax
let's say you pulled ev every hundred
thousand dollars you pull out
you're gonna send 25 grand or so to the
government that 25 grand is going to
continue to make you money
in there over the top using the
government's what is effectively going
to become the government's money it's
going to make you money
so i don't want to send it to them until
i have to uh the only downside is we may
see some bumps in tax rates
uh in the current political climate so
we'll see
hey thank you for calling this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host
today phone number is triple eight eight
two five
five two two five kim is with us in new
york city hi kim how are you
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
i'm considering
i'm considering selling my investment
property to use as a down
payment for a new home the issue is i
bought it for 375k
and it looks like i'm probably going to
end up selling it for 345k so it'll be
at a loss
loss will i still get hit with capital
gains
no capital gains are based me you didn't
do a 1031 into it you didn't trade into
it did you
no i didn't no you you don't have a
capital gain if you're not gaining
so uh oh okay that's how you know so
you're fine why is it losing money
current situation in new york well yeah
so i bought it during that whole bubble
so it was when you know rates were high
for homes
and now it just never again it never
went back up to that price point again
from 2008 or from covid yes
no from 2004 so for 15 years it never
went back up to 375.
wow i am getting rid of that yeah it's
it's a it's definitely not a keeper yeah
that doesn't sound like it's been a fun
experience i'm with you i'll take my
loss
take my lumps and move on yeah right
right right you can see a tax
professional to be sure i'm not a tax
pro i don't even do my own taxes
but i've been doing real estate uh
thousands of real estate transactions
through my life and so i do know capital
gains law
and you do not have a capital gain if
there's not a gain it's a pretty simple
thing
um wait a minute
you know what you need to see your tax
pro because who's been doing your taxes
will give you your adjusted basis
you've been depreciating it for 15 years
and so you've been lowering your basis
for 15 years your basis for tax
calculations could be less than 345
it is not what you paid for it it's what
you paid for it minus the depreciation
you've been taking on your taxes
that's your adjusted basis and that
might be below 345 so you might have a
gain
but i don't have any way of knowing what
that is you'd have to look at your last
tax return or talk to your
tax pro but if you've been
systematically depreciating the thing
for 15 years
you may have a hundred thousand dollar
gain you very well could
so so walk me through that i know that
if i
have a tractor for my farm i'm going to
depreciate that every year because it's
actually losing value yeah and when you
sell it if you depreciate it on your
taxes
as a business transaction as a business
tractor not a gentleman's tractor
but yeah then then it's going down in
value
right and but how do you do that with a
house i thought a house
with with a it's not the loss in value
but it's the same concept
you are allowed to write off one
thirtieth of the house every year
i did not know and so as a tax of the
uh not the lot but of the actual capital
improvements so let's just
make up a number let's say that uh she
paid 375 the lot was worth 75
she's got 300 000 worth of capital
improvements that can be written off
over 30 years
then that's 10 000 a year regardless if
that house could be worth a million
dollars
you can still write off well it doesn't
matter what it's worth
your body people can depreciate you can
take 10 000 of loss
against your income depreciation in that
case
if you divided 300 000 by 30 okay uh
each year
but then that lowers your basis
and so if let's say it was 10 000 and
you did that for 15 years that's 150
000 you've lowered your basis now when
you sell it
everything above that lowered basis is a
gain
ah well played okay and so she's going
to have a gain
if she's been depreciating that house
and she probably has yep
most people that have rental property do
take the depreciation because
in a sense you know if you got ten
thousand dollars and you made ten
thousand dollars
in rental income on the house you had
tax free income right so well shelter is
sheltered
real estate has a tax shelter to it
that's what a tax shelter is
that's what that's where the phrase
comes from all right colleen is with us
in augusta georgia hey colleen how are
you
hi dave how are you thanks for taking my
call sure how can we help
i well i'm in a little bit of a bind or
a pickle
i recently came across your program
through my church it was
given to us and i started following your
program about a month ago
i am on baby step two
though i've already completed baby step
three and i know you're gonna say
you know what you're gonna say but my
concern and worry is
um i have my husband his income has been
kind of unstable so i'm a little nervous
about depleting
savings and throwing it to my last debt
so i guess i just need some advice
okay um
well you're right you're not doing the
baby steps you're doing your plan
but the uh the thing how unstable is his
income i mean do you think he's going to
lose his job
um he's been having some some problems
with some struggles
and has had to go away at times to
seek some treatment and um
kind of left me holding the bag which is
fine because i feel like we make
enough income to is he still fighting
the addiction
yes okay all right
and what do you make and what does he
make
uh i make about 80 000 a year
and he's around 50. okay
and how much debt do you have and how
much is in savings
i have a 18 000
car loan and a 24 000
personal loan with zero interest and the
car loan is about i don't know 1.79 and
i've
actually been able to spend and how much
how much debt do you have i mean how
much
how much savings do you have 17 000
okay so there's not
really a a way to work it in our system
like you're working it
what we tell folks is one of two things
one is work the system and that would be
pull the set pull 16 of 17 out
throw it at this situation i would not
do that in your situation
the second way to address this is i have
i'm in the middle of a storm
and so we don't work the baby steps we
just push pause
and we pile up cash
okay how long has he been struggling
with this and how long have you all been
married
we've been married about six years and
he's been
struggling for about two that i was
aware of i guess i i kind of what what's
he addicted to
uh mostly alcohol which relates to a lot
of ptsd
wartime issues and things of that nature
he's hurting and he's hurting you
in the process y'all are hurting and so
you don't need to be working in intense
baby steps program you need to be piling
up cash and addressing this
and you don't need an eighteen thousand
dollar car debt so you probably ought to
move down in car
until you all get this situated because
anything we can do to have more cash and
less debt
stabilizes your life while you fight
through this and make these decisions
i'm so sorry but let me tell you what
you let me tell you what you can't do
you can't continue to sort of do life
while he sort of fights this
and i'm sort of going to work a plan
because i sort of hope this is all sort
of okay
it's kind of all in or all out am i
missing something john no that's 100
right and i love dave you just said it
right
this isn't a time to be gazelle intense
because somebody's hurt right
and if you even if you pile up cash and
you put it in your checking account
and just even mentally you can tick off
we're getting closer and closer
in six months in a year you're able to
just write that check and
and pay your debt down and pay your debt
off um
but he needs to go full in and get this
thing taken care of or to get on a pad
you don't get taken care of in that way
but you need to go
full full adventure here to go get on a
new road to getting well and he needs
you by a side in that
in that process yeah you you you're you
don't
you don't glide in the middle with ptsd
with addictions resulting from it
there's no middle
can i ask you can i ask you this
question calling um okay
actually let's do this can we hang on
sure and roll over hang on here and
we'll catch you after the break and um i
want to ask you a question as we follow
up here
yeah we'll make sure we walk with you
because your financial stuff is is
ending up being the symptom of all these
other things and the fact you can't move
forward is the symptom of all these
other things so we got to help you with
the whole picture and this this is a
good man who's been wounded
and we want to help him it's hard hard
stuff
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day hebrews 10 23
let us hold fast to the confession of
our hope
without wavering for he who promised
is faithful amelia barr says it is
always the simple
that produces the marvelous there we go
we're talking with colleen in augusta
georgia
the young man that she married has uh
some ptsd and is resulting in some
alcohol
ism and not some is and
um uh so his income's unstable because
he's been
apparently in and out of rehab a couple
times and so she's trying to figure out
how to work the steps during that
we told her don't just shut down pile up
cash and let's work on getting
him well so that we are well so that we
can plan our future out
and that's where we left it john does
that sound right colleen
yes that's right so let me ask you this
um sometimes folks
who are married they love somebody
struggling with addiction
that's such a helpless feeling it's such
a unmoored unstable feeling that they
start looking around their world
and trying to grab hold of anything they
can control
and just start doing it really hard is
there a part of this situation where you
feel powerless
as he's going up and down struggling
with this
that this debt journey is a way that you
can grab
control here or are you just looking at
your budget and you're terrified
we can't hear you you can't hear your
call your phone went sideways
oh i'm sorry i'm sorry um
i feel like it's a little bit of
everything i feel like i
i it's just been a struggle because i
feel like everything falls on my
shoulders and
not that he's never he's always brought
income to the table
we just lost you colleen
yeah we just lost you there um
yeah dave as i was saying that that
powerless feeling and
it's always brings like she was saying
always brings income to the table
sometimes he does sometimes he doesn't
the tendency is is just to say
what can i do to make myself safe and
then you
jump into a program like this that only
works if both of you are on the same
page
right and one of you really gets
dedicated to a process and the other
person's kind of in and out and not
healthy not fully well
and man that undermines the relationship
further
accidentally right and suddenly you're
you're
going head-to-head on how we spend money
going head-to-head on um
are you making money and then it just
separates you from the inside out
i love the idea of stacking cash making
sure on on the same page if you've got
to do something
help him when his debt-free journey
yeah i mean
yeah and i would other than that i would
just pile up cash as high as i could
pile cash
to get rid of that eighteen thousand
dollar car line right not because it's
an expensive car but just it's a dadgum
car line
and i'd like for you to be free anything
we can do to make
less stress so you can pile up more
money so you can address the real issue
that's right
and the real issue is to help him get
some healing
um and uh it sounds like he's a wounded
warrior yep
psychologically those are hard man hard
moments it's a tough it's a tough thing
to go through
and time we love him and thanks for his
service
and um and then you guys work and
um let's get everybody on the same page
with an ongoing coach an ongoing
counselor
a 12-step program and a rehab or
whatever you need get it all lined up
and pay for it let's do it let's get it
done
and plug it in with a va whatever you
got to do to get the help and
and uh and you get a clear eye you can't
accept this
as an ongoing i don't
i don't want to project this for you
that's why i put you on hold and held
you was through this was i don't want to
project this for you
i don't want you projecting this
instability in and out in and out in and
out as the way of life for the next 10
years
no or 20 years no that's not okay
that becomes co-dependent on your part
and it will get with somebody with ptsd
and i'll close them
that will get increasingly unstable
right that will continue to devolve into
they're gonna say they're gonna heal or
it's gonna get worse that's right and so
um you gotta be working on the healing
side of it to where you say okay we have
a
number of years two years three years
whatever we're going to be
clear of this and we're going to look
back in our rearview mirror and go well
that was crappy
and i'm glad we did it together and i'm
glad we held on
and now let's work take this pile of
cash
and let's work on through and let's get
going and let's and i tell you you want
to you want to accomplish a goal
get a clear-eyed well-focused
veteran by your side man you're going to
go fly through these baby steps right
there's there's it's it's hard to stop
oh you mean
you mean him healed i thought man he's
gonna be the greatest partner you ever
had yeah because i mean
you know once you've been through that
stuff he's gonna be you know you've been
under a live fire uh
credit card that done but it's not it's
not a big thing you know that's right
so i i want every veteran listening to
this
driving down the road by yourself if
you're struggling
please please not for anybody else but
for yourself
do what you got to do to go get well go
see somebody go talk to somebody
and then you're going to realize it is
for yourself but it's also for your kids
it's also for your wife it's also your
husband
go get help but the healed version
has an unbelievable ability to focus
to do anything and a and a and a
a a rewired discipline yeah
that is there and it's a foundation
that's what you mean
you say a clear-eyed veteran you know
they're they have a
you know there's just built-in
priorities yeah
and um don't sweat the small stuff and
it's all small stuff
hey i'll never forget man i i can tell
you who he is right now
i was walking down i was working at a
law school or walking down the hall
and i said man all right
it was exam time and law school exams
are hard and i said man are you stressed
and he said well sir nobody shot at me
today and i'm in the air conditioning so
i'm doing all right and i remember going
whoa
what a perspective there's an old sales
old sales uh
motivational story of the guy that won
uh
you know the number one sales guy for
one of the big uh
or one of the big franchises in in real
estate
and they brought him up on stage to give
him the trophy number one in the whole
nation
said you know well you know how did you
do this and he goes well it's not hard
you just talk to people about houses and
they buy houses and he said what do you
mean
he goes well like i walked in burger
king the other day and i was sitting
there and looked over and there's a
young couple looking at homes magazine
i went over and said hey y'all looking
at houses they said yeah and uh uh
they ended up selling them house they
said well weren't you scared to walk up
to strangers and he said
i did two tours in vietnam i'm not
scared of people in burger king
i'll tell you what a clear-eyed
clear-eyed veteran
will help solve our community challenges
will be the best husband you could ever
have the best wife you could ever have
um go get the help you need yeah go do
it
yeah and she she's brave to be fighting
this beside him but
don't don't go all in don't be under the
illusion that you can sort of do this
stuff you gotta go all in
and you you can do enough over here
while he
is over here tearing it down that's
right that's not that's never going to
work that's not
all in on healing first and then go do
the baby steps and you are going to sail
through new baby step you have a new
baby step yeah you got to do this before
you start the baby steps i like
it that's that's what it amounts to and
um that's true in any situation where
there is a crisis of some kind
and you know what you guys are facing is
a crisis and a lot of pain a lot of hurt
and uh we'll be praying for you we love
you yeah and we appreciate his service
we appreciate your
her service man your your uh your
bravery
and you know staring this demon down
yeah if you hold on uh kelly if you can
that phone went sideways like she
dropped it down the garbage disposal i
don't know but
if you're still there kelly will pick up
and uh
we'll try to get you on john's show
later and maybe he can walk you through
some other stuff and
uh you know walk you through the the
whole process
personal finance folks is 80 behavior
we all know what to do it's 20 of
knowledge yep it's not a lack of
knowledge
it's a matter of being able to do it and
since it's 80
behavior it's also 80 relationships i
was gonna say
dysfunctional toxic screwed up twisted
messed up
family extended family uh misbehavior
addictions
uh laziness whatever it is going on
in people's lives um affects your
finances more than your lack of
knowledge about how to do the math
get people in your life if you find out
hey i can't stop eating this thing i
can't stop drinking this thing i can't
stop filling the blank
get people in your life there you go
good show john thank you ma'am
nice job james childs and kelly daniel
in the booth i am dave ramsey
your host we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
you